what happens when you spend most of your
life doing a job only to see it
disappear
I'm from the generation from where hard
work should pay off and I said that was
only said they owed us because they were
also making money what happens when one
of your town's largest financial
contributors leaves this is the story of
how one company's failure impacted
people places and a nation when Toys R
has said it was closing all its Us
stores it didn't just mean the end of an
iconic brand it was also the end of
thousands of jobs and millions in tax
revenue the losers in this case of
course in the first instance are the
workers they've lost their jobs and
they're being denied severance hey fam
I'm a Mayan and this Sunday we're
telling you how one retail giant
collapsed and what we might be seeing a
lot more still is following in its
footsteps spoiler alert it's not just
Amazon's fault
Wall Street's involved too so yeah it's
kind of funny that uh that's how much
help I needed to know bad it was that's
the finished product so I'm proud of
that one this is the first time
anne-marie Reinhart has ever had to do a
resume when she began working at Toys R
Us 29 years ago she didn't need one when
I first identity the resume I was like
alright you know I've done this and I'm
just like just jotting that one of those
1 1 or 2 words down I had someone look
at it from the Department of Labor oh
she was doing Reinhart spent the first
25 years of her time at Toys R Us in New
York before she moved to North Carolina
she thought she'd retire from Toys R Us
she thought that even as she saw signs
of its financial difficulties and its
restructuring she thought that even
after the company tried to reassure
employees I don't want to get too
emotional because when I really start
talking about it I guess
can you give me that means I feel like
coming on in September they had file for
chapter 11 obviously you know that was a
red flag for all of us then Dave Brandon
sent a letter to everyone in the country
stating you know um you know nobody to
be alarmed everything's got to be fine
we just restructuring it alone
everything would not be fine for Toys R
Us right art is one of 33,000 employees
who lost a job when Toys R Us went
bankrupt her store in Durham shut down
in the first wave of closures in
February the last doors closed shop at
the end of June I'm starting to get
scared I'm not gonna lie I'm starting to
get scared because I've been looking for
a job and unemployment runs out in about
four weeks the stores road from
profitability to bankruptcy is the tale
of what can happen when Wall Street
steps in to try and turn a company
around economist Eileen Applebaum says
when private equity buys retailers like
Toys R Us often the investors win while
the company and its employees suffer
when private equity owns the company and
sells off the real estate the company
does not get the money the money goes
directly to the private equity firm and
its investors there's nothing in it for
them for the for the retail company and
this makes no sense from the perspective
of having a strong business it only
makes sense from the point of view of
the private equity firms see even if a
company like Toys R Us goes bankrupt the
private equity firms still make money
through things like charging millions
and fees to the retailer or selling off
all the company's real estate Toys R Us
was actually turning a profit when it
filed for bankruptcy how profitable was
it it was responsible for one out of
every five toys sold in the u.s. in 2017
but the retailer was saddled with
millions of dollars in debt thanks to
the private equity firms that bought it
too much debt for its profits to make a
difference the interest expenses alone
or four hundred million dollars a year
so if you're paying a four hundred
million dollars a year in just interest
expenses not to mention that you're also
paying rent not to mention that you're
also paying these advisory fees
there's not a whole lot left to invest
in the company private equity firms
found toys-r-us enticing in 2005
even though competitors like wal-mart
were already putting the squeeze on the
company that's when Bain Capital KKR and
Company and Varnado Realty Trust bought
the toy retailer what often happens with
private equity is that they say their
goals are to invest money cut costs and
improve efficiency and all while trying
to maximize profits private equity makes
its money if it boosts the company's
perceived value and then sells it and
the majority of the dollars and cents
they're using in this game aren't even
their own the companies who are owned by
private equity firms are at risk of
bankruptcy if they can't pay off their
debt the private equity firm puts in a
little bit of money to that fund very
little and the pension funds and other
investors put up the rest
so they're basically playing with other
people's money the private equity firm
puts in one or two dollars for every
hundred that the investors put in so the
private equity firms have very little
skin in the game very little that they
can lose companies like Bain Capital
helps save soars like Burlington Coat
Factory Dollar General and Restoration
Hardware and they've made plenty of
money in the process
but for every Burlington there's a
Sports Authority a Gymboree a Payless
and a Toys R Us yeah they took the
letters off the building
Wow those are just a few of the
retailers that went bankrupt in 2016 and
2017 p/e owned businesses are accounting
for an increasing share of chapter 11
bankruptcy 'he's part of why we're
seeing these companies go bust right now
is because of over investment in
property during the mid-2000s large
big-box stores kept going up I did
property values many considered
purchasing big-box retail space as savvy
investment at the time the bet didn't
pay off and the effect of the so-called
retail apocalypse has been widespread
overall retail employment has been
falling you've probably seen your local
mall with a few empty storefronts
department stores like Macy's and JC
Penney shed nearly a hundred thousand
jobs between October 2016 and April 2017
that's more than the total number of
coal miners or steel workers we so often
hear President Trump talk about the
retail problem is impacting every region
the nation's richest cities are also
seeing retail struggle New York City had
three years of falling employment at
clothing stores as of 2017 a streak like
that hasn't happened since the early
1990s when stores disappear jobs vanish
and so does the money those companies
contribute to local economies people
came to downtown in a small town because
they were going to go shopping for toys
and while they were there they visited
the other stores as well and the same
thing is true of laws these malls and
Main streets are losing a major anchor
store so communities suffer lenders
suffer vendors suffer and worst of all
the employees suffer now some of those
laid off retail workers like mine Hart
are fighting just to get severance
announced the end of February beginning
of March we're about halfway through our
liquidation still no word on what the
severance package was and that's when we
found out that we were not getting any
severance and we found via phone it
would be above all this is a company
that traditionally paid severance all
the way up to
20:16 beer before the bankruptcy they
were still paying severance when they
laid off workers and now they've refused
to do that
torres is headquartered in Wayne New
Jersey it paid more than 2.7 million
dollars to the town on its property in
taxes last year the former toy giant is
Wayne's third largest taxpayer according
to Moody's Wayne is now out exactly 1159
jobs which is the equivalent to 2% of
its population and millions in taxes to
fund town services when toys-r-us leaves
the lot it sits on will decrease in
value if it's vacant for too long that's
true of all 740 Toys R Us stores that
shut down in the u.s. right now the
future of all those vacated properties
is as unclear as Reinhart employment
prospects we don't know what will happen
the one thing that is certain is that
Reinhart is done looking for retail work
I'm definitely not looking to go back
into retail it did leave a little bit of
a bad taste in my mouth I never ever
dreamed at my age that I would be out
there meeting and looking for a job
so that part gets a little emotional hey
Pam thanks for watching don't forget to
Like share and subscribe this is the
first of two stories we're doing on
bankruptcy come back next weekend to see
the other one and we'll see you next
Sunday